I don't I cannot promise that this will
be perfect in one go because it's very
recently there's been a new paper
published about how the periodic table
could get enormous ly bigger than we
imagine now at the moment the periodic
table looks pretty complete all 118
elements and each has its little hole
where it sits and by and large we
understand the structure pretty well
each element has a nucleus in the middle
that contains protons that are
positively charged and neutrons that
have no charge and electrons going round
and the shape of the periodic table
where all the elements it is dictated by
how the electrons are arranged around
the nucleus now in this case a finished
chemist or he may be physicists I don't
have a finished scientist has asked what
would happen if we put a lot more
electrons into atoms made them very much
bigger so he's not looking at the
nucleus at all but just looking at the
way the electrons are arranged and the
point is that at the moment the
electrons can go into four types of
slightly different shells which are
called by strange names SP d NF the
letters come from old-fashioned names
sharp principle diffuse and fundamental
but nobody ever uses those names just
the letters now the excitement of going
higher in the periodic table is that a
new sort of shell called G g4 George
jeev Germany I don't know which has
never been seen and the question is how
that would fill up and what's
interesting about the periodic table at
the moment is the electrons fill up in
an order that is not quite what one
might expect that's why in the periodic
table at the moment we get these groups
of elements the
earth and the actinides the uranium type
elements which are separate because they
really fill it fit in to the space here
between barium and hafnium you concede
there's a space there with no letters
but just lots of numbers 57 to 71 and so
on
the question is if you have another row
where will the G electrons fit in so
this is the paper published in the
journal called PCCP only a few days ago
and if we turn over the page we can see
what his conclusion is here is the
periodic table as we know up to this
line with the holes here we're 57 to 71
and 89 to 103
15 and so his calculations show that
when you get to 118 as you might expect
you get 100 1920 and then at a hundred
and twenty this G row here you can see
5g comes in so it's in a special place
that goes to 138 nobody has any idea
what they might be called because if we
ever made them there'd only be one or
two atoms but these G elements and then
what is interesting is that after there
he calculates the next two elements will
go here 3900 3940 underneath boron and
carbon but then there'll be another hole
then you'll go through a whole string
from 141 to 155
so the periodic table will suddenly have
another gap that will appear here and
then when you get to 155 instead of
going on along here you jump down to
bare and then to there before you go
back to there that's a right old mess
well it's quite surprising
it's only a calculation nobody knows
whether he's right and what's more to
the point I very much doubt if anybody
will prepare all of these elements
within either my lifetime or the
lifetime of anybody reading these papers
so you can ask what's the point of doing
this and the answer is that these are
interesting calculations because perhaps
by doing these calculations we will
understand a bit more about our present
periodic table at the moment the
periodic table is quite nice and compact
fits inside my pen but if we had this
bigger one it would just go on and on
and on so from the point of view of
chemistry we haven't learnt very much
from this periodic table but what it's
done is to make us think and anything
that makes scientists think is really
good